hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are doing an
unboxing
that i think is very exciting
because it's something that i feel like
i
wanted to exist my entire childhood and
only just now has come out listen it
doesn't have a real pokemon in it so we
haven't quite fulfilled my dream of
being a pokemon master
this thing pretty close
so here it is this is a pokeball
it's water on it we are getting this
poke ball which
is beautiful but there's more to it than
just that and also
this display case um it actually comes
with the box here that has a latch to
open and
maybe it lights up who knows maybe
that's why it says electronic no
spoilers it describes itself as a
display grade electronic replica with a
metal shell with fine detail and premium
painted finish
touch and proximity sensing technology
what
i didn't even know that part what touch
to illuminate display
individually numbered batteries included
this premium quality highly accurate
pokeball replica
is perfectly sized with an engineered
metal shell that electronically senses
proximity and touch
with its brightly illuminated button and
lift to display illuminated presentation
case this poke ball promises to be a
beautiful addition to any pokemon
collection this is actually the second
uh pokemon collectible that i've
acquired this year this one was a gift
from a loved one
um but let me like google price well no
but that's rude
isn't it shouldn't i not do that i'm not
going to do that i was going to say i'll
look up where it's from and do all that
stuff but because it was a gift
i'm sorry are you gonna have to do that
yourself i will note that it says the
wand company
real hero collectibles on the back and i
believe this person bought it from
sideshow
but i'm not sure i'm i'm very sorry this
is
the worst unboxing i've done yet but uh
yeah i have actually bought a number of
pokemon collectibles this year
the other one i have not posted anyway
yet i haven't even shared that i got it
the hype is like a little bit too real i
did share
the buff pokemon that i got uh at the
end of last year
the swole pikachu squirtle charmander
bulbasaur but i've also tried not to
promote those too much
because i found out that i accidentally
bought bootlegs which um
i don't want to encourage people to buy
ultimately but you know if you don't
know me
uh charlanazad which is my username
across all social media platforms is my
name with charizard in the middle of it
i have two pokemon tattoos
and while i don't feel like i'm uh as
much of a consistent ongoing pokemon fan
i mean
look i still play pokemon go with great
frequency and i'm very excited about
pokemon snap
truthfully i do like a lot of other
people just really love the original 150
151 pokemon and feel like uh it shaped
my life in a really significant way as
it did for most people who were kids
in the year 2000. so i sort of like
credit pokemon with a lot of my career
um and this is definitely something i've
wanted my whole life the one other thing
is those
pokedexes that i'm rambling let's open
the thing
it comes with a leaflet there you go
this is
battery information it says important
which means
i'm not going to read it okay worth
noting on here this does say
www.thewandcompany.compokeball
so that's where you guys can go to find
out more information i'm not going to
google it
so i don't ruin my own gift all right
let's slide
the thumb out here
i mean this is even cool this foam box
has
a pokeball on it my lighting setup does
not like that but it's cool
and lift the phone oh we have
it is wrapped in some good good plastic
this beautiful
pokeable it is a lot heavier
than you'd think this thing is sturdy
and i think one of the things i like
about that compared to
every other pokeball i have owned of
which yes i have owned numerous
um this one feels like it would feel
like the actual pokeballs feel i think
so what happens
if we press button okay i turned my
light off so you guys can see because it
actually did nothing otherwise
can't quite see kenya
that's a tough one there can you see
that that's a light
oh man so right now it's actually sort
of pulsating a little bit
okay we are turning more lights off the
problem is that this webcam
which is new is actually too good
at low light compensation
well you can see it okay so it's lit up
right now if i hit it again
it goes red and then fades off i'm sure
it has more modes than that
but that's the idea so
the box this thing i imagine is what has
the
like motion sensor proximity sensor
it says pokeball on it it's got this
lovely pokeball etched into the top of
it
and then when you open it that lights up
which i feel is so cool because
this is the way that a pokemon in a
pokeball
um that you would get from a vendor and
not like catch in the wild is most
frequently presented
so if we pair the two we have
our beautiful pokeball
in our beautiful display box close it
and open it yeah the light at the bottom
you can see it rings around as soon as
you open the case up
that is neat i'm a fan
very cool this thing is awesome
and yeah if you didn't know this is the
first like officially licensed um
premium collectible replica line that's
why this is such a big deal and why it's
so well made
okay i just okay this thing as it turns
out
the name plate is what makes it change
color
attack my gosh um i'm gonna flip the
camera to my iphone camera because i
think that'll show up the color but if
you guys which is
genuinely just because this camera is so
good in low light uh
not the fault of the camera but we will
swap to my iphone real quick
okay so here is the pokeball here's what
happens
if you move it or it senses motion i
think it did that
before i touched it what that's so cool
it's currently red because i have it set
to red i believe if i touch that
it'll change yeah well maybe it's going
through a cycle right now
that's so wild
and pick it up
green still obviously very blown out but
you get the idea
and then it's white
and it goes off when we stop touching it
it's just so unnecessarily cool i'm such
a fan
um yeah let me show you guys the case a
little bit better as well
so i think like i showed the case itself
off relatively well but to show you guys
the lighting in here
tap that goes green
yellow blue purple
pinkish i guess
yeah it just alternates between colors
so this obviously
sits on here and if we lift this up
and then pretend to pick it up
everything is just super lit up i think
it's so neat uh the one complaint that i
will make and i hope it's not because
i'm doing something wrong is
how easily it closes um but maybe
there's like something i need to change
to stop it from snapping shut like that
because i would love to display it like
this all the time you know
it just seems to want to close itself
because it's pretty sturdily weighted
okay lights are back on truly when i
thought my unboxings couldn't get any
worse
here we are you know it just didn't it
didn't play great on camera but
uh the motion controls on this thing
it's so cool um i really do love how
sturdy it is i'm a huge fan of the
design this thing has triple a batteries
in it
uh the base does as well um and i think
they they suit each other
beautifully it's just yeah it's really
the pokeball that i feel like i've
always wanted
it's it's sturdy it's solid i'm just
gonna have to try not to like
throw it and hope that a pokemon comes
out one day because
that's what i want to happen in this
situation
i can't stop okay so
it's on right now it's off on
i just love video games and video game
toys make me very happy but that is it
for me today everyone
the most awkward unboxing of all time
because i upgraded my webcam and the low
light
is too good apologies
for that uh but thank you all for
watching just another video where i
you know i like showing off stuff that
i'm happy about because i feel like it
brings good vibes
um and that's pretty much it i will see
you all next time bye